♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
THIS WEEK SCOTT ELLIS LEFT HIS
POSITION OF WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS ADVISOR PAID FOR
YEARS HE WAS A SENIOR MEMBER OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY’S DEPARTMENT
OF MEDICINE.
I KNOW STANFORD WELL AND TAUGHT
THERE WHEN I FIRST MOVED TO
AMERICA IN 2012 AND OF ALWAYS
BEEN GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THEY GAVE ME BUT ON
NOVEMBER 20 THE UNIVERSITY
EQUITY SENATE CONDEMNED DR.
ATLAS AND SAID HIS ACTIONS
QUOTE, CONTRADICT MEDICAL
SCIENCE AND CLAIMED HE
MISREPRESENTED KNOWLEDGE AND
OPINION REGARDING THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE PANDEMIC SHOWING DISDAIN
FOR ESTABLISHMENT KNOWLEDGE AND
ALLEGED HE VIOLATED STANFORD’S
CORE VALUES AND HIGH ETHICAL
STANDARDS.
HIGH ETHICAL STANDARDS BUT
INTERESTING.
EARLIER IN THE YEAR THREE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF STANFORD
MEDICAL FACULTY EPIDEMIOLOGIST,
JAY AND AARON PUBLISHED A STUDY
THAT COMPLETELY OFFENDED WHAT WE
THOUGHT WE KNEW ABOUT THE VIRUS
AND BY TESTING ANTIBODIES WHERE
STANDARD IS BASED THE DOCTORS
ESTABLISH THAT CORONAVIRUS IS
MUCH MORE INFECTIOUS BUT MUCH
LESS DEADLY AND THEN WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD FOR THIS FINDING
CALLED INTO QUESTION THE ENTIRE
STRATEGY OF OUR LEADERS BLOCKING
EVERYONE DOWN TO TRY TO STOP
ANYONE BEING INFECTED.
IF THE VIRUS WAS AS INFECTIOUS
AS THE STANFORD DOCTORS SHOWED
THERE WAS NO POINT IN SHOWING ON
THE ECONOMY BECAUSE THAT WOULD
NOT STOP THE VIRUS AND IF IT’S
MUCH LESS DEADLY THAN FOR MOST
PEOPLE IT DOESN’T MATTER BECAUSE
THEY WILL HAVE ZERO SYMPTOMS IF
THEY GET INFECTED.
THE RIGHT POLICY WOULD BE TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE WHILE
LETTING EVERYONE ELSE GET ON
WITH THEIR LIVES.
THIS WAS HUGELY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE ON THE SHOW WE WERE THE
FIRST TO CRITICIZE THE LOCKDOWNS
AND TO SAY THE CURE IS WORSE
THAN THE DISEASE.
WE BROUGHT YOU THE STANFORD
DOCTORS FINDINGS AS SOON AS THEY
WERE AVAILABLE, THE DOCTOR
JOINED US ON APRIL 12.
WHAT WAS THE REACTION FROM
STANFORD?
THIS MAN LLOYD MINOR IS HEAD OF
STANFORD MEDICINE AND INSTEAD OF
SUPPORTING HIS COLLEAGUES
GROUNDBREAKING WORK HE TRIED TO
SILENCE THEM AND USING THE
PRETEXT OF A MANUFACTURED
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT HE
ORDERED AN INVESTIGATION FOR SIX
MONTHS THE DOCTORS WERE
THREATENED WITH RETRIBUTION,
HOUNDED BY STANFORD LAWYERS,
PREVENTED FROM SPEAKING OUT AND
EVEN SUBJECTED TO SMEAR
CAMPAIGNS IN THE PRESS.
YET, THEIR PIONEERING FINDINGS
HAVE SINCE BEEN CONFIRMED BY
MULTIPLE OTHER STUDIES IN THIS
ONE CONDUCTED IN JULY AND
PUBLISHED IN SEPTEMBER AND
ANOTHER MORE RECENTLY FROM THE
CDC ITSELF AFTER SIX MONTHS THE
DOCTORS WERE COMPLETELY
EXONERATED AND ABLE TO SPEAK
FREELY AGAIN.
THE DOCTOR BECAME A FOUNDER OF
THE GREAT BARRINGTON DECLARATION
WHICH ARGUES AGAINST LOCKDOWNS
AND IN FAVOR OF WHAT THEY CALL
FOCUSED PROTECTION FOR THE
VULNERABLE.
IT IS THEN SIGNED BY OVER 12000
MEDICAL AND PUBLIC ALL
SCIENTISTS AROUND THE WORLD.
EVERYTHING FROM THE STANFORD
DOCTORS SAID IN APRIL WAS TRUE.
DR. SCOTT ATLAS SHARED THEIR
ANALYSIS AND WAS A VOCAL
ADVOCATE OF THE FOCUSED
PROTECTION APPROACH AND THAT IS
WHY THE PRESIDENT HIRED HIM SO,
WHY DID STANFORD TRY TO SILENCE
ITS OWN DOCTORS?
WHY DID IT SMEAR DR. ATLAS
BECAUSE OF THIS PERSON . SARAH
CODY CLANCY CARA WHO ORDERED THE
NATIONS FIRST LOCKDOWN AND
FANATICS AND HERE IS THE QUEEN
OF CORONA MISINFORMATION, MSNBC
RACHEL MADDOW.
>> DOCTOR CODY AND THE HEALTH
OFFICERS IN THE SAME FOR CISCO
BAY ERICA ACTED FASTER AND MORE
DECISIVELY THAN ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COUNTRY AND I DON’T KNOW
THAT STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS WERE
WITHIN THE PUBLIC HEALTH TOOLKIT
TOOLKIT.
HOW PREPARED WERE YOU, HOW DID
YOU ALL KNOW TO THINK ABOUT
THESE THINGS AS OPTIONS?
STEVE: GOOD QUESTION.
HERE IS THE ANSWER.
THE LOCKDOWN PLAN SARAH CODY
ORDERED HAS BEEN INFECTED SO TO
SPEAK THE WHOLE COUNTRY BUT
WASN’T FORMULATED IN RESPONSE TO
THE CORONAVIRUS BUT WASN’T OFF
THE SHELF PLAN THAT SHE AND
FORMER COLLEAGUES HAVE PREPARED
AFTER 911 AS A RESPONSE TO
POTENTIAL BIOTERRORISM ATTACK OR
A THEORETICAL PANDEMIC, NOT ON
THE DATA OR THE SCIENCE OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
STILL, SARAH CODY SHOT DOWN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND THEN THE
BAY AREA FOLLOWED AND THEN ALL
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEN ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY TOLD WE HAVE
THE BEST PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM IN
THE WORLD AND THIS WEEK DATA WAS
PUBLISHED SHOWING THAT THE VIRUS
WAS CIRCULATING IN MID- DECEMBER
THIS YEAR DOCTOR ANTHONY FAUCI
WAS TELLING US THERE WAS NOTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT AND THE VIRUS WAS
HERE THREE MONTHS BEFORE SARAH
CODY’S LOCKDOWN AND IT WAS NOT
GOING TO CONTAIN IT, EVEN AT THE
TIME THE STANFORD ANTIBODY
STUDIED LITERALLY CONDUCTED IN
SARAH CODY’S COUNTY PROVE THAT
LOCKDOWNS WERE NEVER GOING TO
CONTAIN IT.
YET, PREPOSTEROUSLY GIVEN THE
DATA SARAH CODY WAS STILL
TALKING INTO THIS YEAR ABOUT
QUOTE, FULL CONTAINMENT.
WHAT HAS THIS GOT TO DO WITH
STANFORD AND DR. ATLAS?
GUESS WHO SARAH CODY’S HUSBAND
IS?
A PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT
STANFORD AND SO THEY CLOSE RANKS
TO PROTECT THEIR OWN.
THIS IS LED BY STANFORD
MEDICINE’S BOSS LLOYD MINOR AND
HOW DARE ANYONE QUESTION THE
LOCKDOWN THAT WAS ORDERED BY THE
WIFE OF OUR COLLEAGUE.
THIS IS HOW THE GROUPTHINK
STARTED.
THE STANFORD STUDY WAS THE FIRST
SCIENTIFIC CHALLENGE TO THE
LOCKDOWN POLICY SO NATURALLY, IT
HAD TO BE DESTROYED.
THE DISSENTING DOCTORS HAD TO BE
ATTACKED, SMEARED IN SILENCE AND
UNIVERSITIES, SCIENCE, THE WHOLE
POINT IS TO BE OPEN TO GATHER
EVIDENCE AND TO DEBATE.
STANFORD DID THE EXACT OPPOSITE
AND THEY ATTEMPTED A COVER-UP
AND IT IS GROTESQUE AND A TOTAL
DISGRACE.
MEANWHILE, THE REST OF US HAD TO
LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES AND
THE LOCKDOWN GROUP THINK SPREAD
FROM STANFORD TO THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT TO THE MEDIA TO
THE BUREAUCRATS AND THE
DEMOCRATS WITH UTTERLY CYNICAL
BAD FACE REALIZING THE WEAKNESS
OF THEIR OWN POSITIONS AND THEY
ACCUSED ANYONE AGAINST LOCKDOWN
OF WANTING PEOPLE TO DIE.
OF COURSE, PEOPLE DIED DESPITE
THE LOCKDOWNS AND THOUSANDS MORE
DIED BECAUSE OF THE LOCKDOWN.
WE BROUGHT YOU THE TOLL WEEK
AFTER WEEK AND THE
ESTABLISHMENTS CRUEL,
DESTRUCTIVE LOCKDOWNS FAILED AND
YET HERE WE ARE AGAIN ABOUT TO
REPEAT THEM.
NONE OF IT IS BASED ON SCIENCE
OR DATA AND BIG BUSINESS OR
SMALL BUSINESS CLOSED BUT IT IS
ALL CAPRICIOUS, PSEUDOSCIENTIFIC
NONSENSE AND LOOK AT BIDEN WITH
ITS PATHETIC STATEMENT ABOUT
MASKING IN HIS FIRST HUNDRED
DAYS BUT IT IS PURE BS.
IT’S PLUCKED OUT OF THIN AIR BY
SOME PR IDIOTS AND EVERYTHING
BIDEN SAYS ABOUT THE VIRUS IS
FOR POLITICS, NOT PUBLIC HEALTH.
HE HAS ZERO CREDIBILITY.
LOCKDOWN LEADERS KNOW THE RULES
MAKE NO SENSE OR THEY WOULDN’T
BREAK THEM ALL THE TIME.
EVERY DAY THERE IS A NEW
DEMOCRAT LOCKDOWN HYPOCRITE.
WHAT MORAL AUTHORITY TO THEY
HAVE TWO IMPOSE LOCKDOWNS ON
ANYONE ANYWHERE?
THEY ARE EXPLOITING THIS VIRUS
TO MICROMANAGE OUR LIVES AND WE
HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF IT.
THIS LOCKDOWN GROUPTHINK IS AS
WRONG AS THE ESTABLISHMENT
GROUPTHINK THAT GAVE US ENDLESS
WAR IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND A 50
YEAR SUCK UP TO CHINA.
THIS IS WORSE THEN BOTH BECAUSE
THE COSTS ARE HIGHER.
LOCKDOWNS ARE THE BIGGEST PUBLIC
POLICY MISTAKE IN HISTORY AND WE
HAVE TO FIGHT THEM.
BE RESPONSIBLE, PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE, LIVE YOUR LIFE.
HELP US FIGHT BACK BY FOLLOWING